hey guys Ryan right here and Elissa be
crazy
so Elissa be crazy and I we're gonna
watch the trailer for a game called
blood-borne there's an e at the end of
that on blood-borne yeah
well born a know very little about this
game I know a deals would like a curse
going on creating some monsters and some
[ __ ] it's about as far as my knowledge
goes honestly don't know what to
anticipate really but let's check this
trailer out yep let's do it thank you
with your hair up thank you a lot of
people don't you know what it's in the
ponytail it's really really freaking
long
no that's was pretty interesting about
your hair you have a ponytail yeah let's
move on with our lives now shall we
it's delivering on the blood for sure I
like it it's so creepy from general
softly ooh I like the graphics it kind
of reminds me of like a Sweeney Todd
feel yeah yeah yeah
what what else that that dog
[Music]
hee-hoo
[Music]
that's me yeah
oh I got this box
oh-ho Wow
chillin seriously they did such a good
job with that trailer and I don't have
it all of it or none of it really is
gonna be actual gameplay but they did a
really good job at that trailer they did
a fantastic job
it does have that Sweeney Todd buy that
you were talking about and this isn't
like another virus thing though like a
know what if it is it doesn't seem like
it really kind of scene a little bit I
don't know it seems like you don't even
know why but what's that movie with Will
Smith I am Legend yes yes yes oh yeah an
infection movie yeah well I was
elaborating on what you said you're
really excited about an example I know
but I already kind of said what it was
you know like in it I thought that it
would be nevermind we're moving past it
it's okay it's okay
it's not a big deal I don't I don't know
what I'm doing it's not a big deal I
think they did a really good job they
had that like creepy-sounding overlay
because so many trailers like amp it up
to be like oh this is gonna be so clear
you're gonna do all the stuff and kill
all these things but this just kept the
consistent creepy vibe I really liked
that has that vibe of like you're gonna
be crawling around and really just
sneaking around until something really
terrifying is gonna happen
so yeah nothing like a good game
maybe piss your pants always American
games I'd get this it's a Japanese game
what am I talking about it is you're
right yeah I hope I got that right girl
someone's really gonna correct me on
that you're right we're gonna put me in
my place
I like the subs because you know what we
do say something wrong or incorrect you
guys pounce on it you know you guys
correct us which i think is cool because
i don't want to give out false
information yes I like it too and you
guys are like dick head [ __ ] you guys
always end the explanation with like
it's actually a Korean game you don't
[ __ ] and that and that's all it's nice
to always followed it up with a
flattering compliment oh yeah you know
anyway guys thanks for letting us know
about that trailer if you're new to this
channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
right here and alyssa has a channel at a
niche ELISA be crazy so it's that time
the time we all the time well Ryan
thanks God for Alyssa's boob graze yeah
my shoulder actually no it was the nip
side actually my shoulder it's part of
my arm Harvey your shoulder didn't touch
down here your shoulders up here right
here is where it touched well there's a
space you turn to the right a little bit
trust me I know when it's a boob some
young 0 he said that there was no shadow
required you know what that means you're
getting a shout out
you're getting a shout out some young 0
that's actually the UH the Chinese name
for Jackie Chan when you translate it I
feel like he's just full of false
information today that is so far from
the truth I know this for a fact
some young that's his name zero to there
is it 2-0 is Sam Young 0 there's the -
what are you talking about
what's the - did you mean - other than
also yeah and what how did I say it - oh
I said zero t oh oh oh
okay yeah no I can see how it's confused
especially when I just have a number and
then I followed it with another number
yes Medrano Medrano and who actually
yeah i know who are you sorry about
the Dothraki who's that a doll frackie
was that like a dolls like do you not
watch Game of Thrones no I don't what is
wrong with you a lot of things
keep it Thrones not watching is one of
them
I know we're gonna have to watch the
first episode after this a lot of people
have made that same promise to me and
never have delivery you are probably the
fifth person who has told me that they
will watch Game of Thrones with me and
they did not do it you guys you guys
we're gonna watch it tonight we are
because this is unacceptable
unacceptable a madrasah shout-out please
bro I need it dude if you need to shout
out well that's what we're here for it
yeah we're here to give shout outs we we
don't actually have worthwhile content
on this channel movie reviews cares
about a short film and a sketch
[ __ ] that [ __ ] it's about the shoutout
you need a shout-out yeah you know we
can acknowledge you as a person
exactly exactly it's a way for us all to
connect this is what I'm doing online
dating through my youtube channel yes
yeah I I figured you know the world kind
of gets to know me and then someone
decides whether or not they want to date
me and they let me know one on the
youtube comment boxes yeah actually true
story wait what like in my life is that
what happened with me my life no I was
just saying that like I'm hoping that
could happen
there you go true story house it's true
story cuz you're not I'm not needing
anyone from the channel I don't know
what you're talking about yeah I know
you needed one so here it is X Patrol
how did he say his first name sorry it's
okay dude it's okay the Lord Jesus still
loves you he's Catholic I can tell by
his name middle of Moya 33 shoutout
would be awesome well it awesome is what
you want
we're gonna give you you should just
carry around sparkles with us tick
litter and go
you said the shadow would be awesome but
I'm here to tell you something right now
I'll be right back
okay dude no you can't say you're gonna
tell somebody something and then just
leave that's not how it works I just
need to erase this so I could teach them
something where is it none weird head
face shout I meant to do it out shout
out equals awesome remember that that's
for you my love is